Arthur does it help have someone to talk  to  [Music]  my mother always tells me to smile and  put on a happy face  she told me I had a purpose to bring  laughter and joy to the world  is it just me  [Music]  or is it getting crazier out there  though your heart is aching smile even  though it's breaking when there are  cloud in the sky  you'll get borrow but if you  and sorrows and maybe tomorrow  what's so funny  just freak  [Applause]  [Music]  Goffin has lost its way  what kind of coward would do something  that cold-blooded someone who hides  behind a mask  [Music]  [Applause]  I used to think that my life was a  tragedy  realize  it's a comedy  [Music]  you just  [Music]